hi my name is Everly and I'm five years
old today Two Chefs are gonna compete to
make my dream dinosaur food
hi Everly hi I'm Katie hi I'm twey nice
to meet you I am a content creator and a
chef here based in LA and I'm really
excited for my first ever I draw you
cook when you see this what do you think
dinosaurs eat trees trees I've lost this
show a few times I I won once I'm really
glad to be back here just like give it
another go I do not cook for kids I
don't really know what they like besides
candy and chocolate is this a big
dinosaur is it a baby dinosaur baby baby
okay that's good to know about portions
I'm feeling shy I think Everly's feeling
shy luckily Katie's there and she's just
holding it together for all of us what
are some of your favorite flavors white
chocolate white chocolate
do you have a favorite food yeah what
Cherry Cherry just like a cherry just
Cherry just the fruit yeah yeah okay I
love how she just responds with yes it's
just so easy because that's me too do
you think the dinosaurs were picky
eaters or do you think they eat
everything eat everything they eat
everything are you like a dinosaur or do
you eat everything no what else do you
think they eat water so is this like
regular water or is it magical water is
it magic oh magical water so what does
magical water look like colorful what
are you even drawing now rocks they eat
rocks too yeah are they Harley are they
are they like you know chewy chewy chewy
I like that I like these rocks chewy
different different rocks flavored pops
seeing a lot of colors and I love that I
just don't know how to incorporate that
does the dinosaur have a name Katie
Katie the dinosaur oh my name I think
that's a great name I like that name
Everly is so cute she's like hey she's
adorable but she's also extremely smart
I'm drawing a yummy rainbow oh do you
know what a rainbow is a reflection and
it has all of the colors I barely knew
that that is gorgeous this is a very
colorful plate so do you think that we
can make this dinosaur food yeah you do
okay take a look Katie good luck thank
you thank you so much we need that we're
gonna need it
we're here how are you feeling I am
feeling very confident how are you
feeling feeling a little nervous
I think Dwayne new to the show gives her
an advantage because she can like bring
in this new energy this new point of
view my game plan is to make a brownie
tree I'm not really sure what I want the
top of it to be yet maybe some chocolate
covered fruits so what I'm thinking
about making today is a Swiss roll tree
that's gonna stand up with these kind of
like Coral looking like green things on
the top to be the top of the tree so now
I'm just going to separate the egg
whites and the egg yolks oh
I just dropped an egg I salvaged it
though so that's good she's a picky
eater it's making me a little nervous
about like how adventurous I can get so
I have my brownie mixture here I added
two eggs and I'm about to add some
canola oil my specialty is definitely
more on the Savory side so like baking
and sweets is just like out of my
comfort zone and cooking for kids is way
out of my comfort zone okay so now I'm
going to mix these eggs with half a cup
of powdered sugar until we get some
stiff peas so my brownie batter is done
now I got some like dinosaur sprinkles
because this is a magical tree did you
like dinosaurs growing up
um I'd never really cared about them I
used to wrap an impression when I was oh
you have to do it now I don't no you
have to do I'm pressuring YouTube right
now
oh Mark I mean
wait she kind of scared me I can't
believe I shared that with all of you so
embarrassing so my brownie batter is
done I'm going to be putting this in the
oven so I've got my egg yolks I'm gonna
do a teaspoon of vanilla and then I'm
gonna do the rest of my powdered sugar I
got my stiff peaks done how stiff is it
so so stiffed way you have to put it
upside down
now I need to bake my egg yolks vanilla
and powdered sugar I have white
chocolate over here I'm going to melt
down to make the top of the tree and add
in a food coloring and matcha powder all
right so I've got cocoa powder
all-purpose flour a little bit of salt
baking powder and baking soda and now
I'm just going to sip in my dry
ingredients this chocolate is seasoning
I think it's just all In the Heat of the
Moment that I forgot to just make a
double boiler for the chocolate the
chocolate is seeming to slow its way
down which is what I really need right
now because I'm very far behind so right
now I'm gonna fold in my egg whites
about a third of them into my mixture
here I'm gonna try to make something
that I've seen Ria make on make it fancy
she made it with Oreos I'm not making it
with Oreos it looks like coral and it's
with flour and water but it doesn't have
much I'm gonna do pandan for the color
pandian is so that's a good move I don't
know
yeah I can see that this cake is very
very thin it's getting me worried about
standing this Swiss roll up I have my
chocolate in here my water's boiling now
we're back that really slowed me down
let me go bake this the chocolate is
melting really beautifully look at that
so now it's time for me to add my matcha
I'm moving on to the filling for my
sweet roll which is some whipped cream a
little bit of sugar and then I have a
secret ingredient it's a little bit of
cherry extract because she said she
likes cherries I can smell that it's
it's a little bit more fake than I'd
like so I've whipped up my whipping
cream and I'm gonna add a little
marshmallow fluff I love a marshmallow
filling and I feel like it would make it
a little bouncier so I'm adding that I'm
actually using a skewer to dip my
strawberries because my fingernails
which is not cutting it
yep the skew is the way to go I'm gonna
put this in the fridge for now and I'm
gonna start prepping for the Swiss roll
to come out of the oven and my
strawberries are done this is a really
beautiful tree top okay here we go here
goes nothing
okay it didn't stick to the pan thank
God it's a little thinner than I
anticipated I'm going the extra mile to
make this component because it's not on
the drawing I am making a a dinosaur
Pop-Tart that's going to live in the
Dinosaur Land toy is making something
that is not in the drawing and like
props to her I've never thought about
doing that and I should I should have
this is just store-bought Pub pastry
nothing special but what's going to make
it really special are these dinosaurs
shapes that's going to make the dinosaur
Pop-Tart so I need to cut outs per
dinosaur so then it can fold on top of
each other the cake is sticking to the
parchment which we don't want so I'm
losing parts of my cake we lost a corner
of the cake that's all right so now this
is gonna go into the fridge to and set
so I have some strawberry jam here that
I will be putting in between it really
could go both ways because she could be
like I didn't ask for a dinosaur or she
could be like wow this is really cute I
appreciate you adding this dinosaur so I
don't know I am now going to move on to
my tree top it's just flour water and
pandan it's something I've never done
before something I'm sorry I do on
makeup fans yeah yes and it looks like
Coral brushing my Pop-Tart with a little
bit of egg wash they look so cute so I'm
gonna use a fork to close off the edges
of the Pop-Tart I don't know what it is
about those Fork marks but it just kind
of makes it look more official that guy
is really cute I am only picking one
perfect dinosaur in my place yes this is
an audition whichever one turns out the
best will appear on the plate my money
is on the um
the long neck a brontosaurus a what a
brontosaurus yeah yes my money is on the
Brontosaurus these dinosaurs are ready
to come alive here I go here I go
I see holes I'd like to see a few
time to make our magical rainbow I saw
this video on Tick Tock where this girl
made sour straws from rice paper and I
thought that was really cool and this is
the perfect time to test that out I'm
making a combination like a mixture of
sugar and citric acid right here where
she wets the rice paper with water and
lime juice I'm not sure why the lime
juice maybe to make it even more sour I
have a whole bunch of different colored
fruits here and I'm going to roll it up
I've never done it before so things
could go wrong oh hey okay okay
dang that looks good this is a thick
sour straw those sour straws are cool
looking I should have gone on Tick Tock
I'm gonna start cutting up some fruit
while this works this is going to be the
rocks and then I have a dragon fruit
here that is red and I'm just going to
use these like tiny little cookie
cutters to cut different shapes into the
dragon fruit now I'm gonna cut kiwi for
the green rocks and then I'll do
blueberries and blackberries are you
gonna cut up the blueberries I know can
you imagine me like cutting like even
smaller blueberries I hope Beverly
appreciates these and it's not too weird
for her I love sour stuff but I don't
know if Everly likes this sour so I'm
gonna be making a rainbow waffle again
another thing I haven't made before so
I'm just using like a regular waffle box
mix I'm not going fancy here are you
very competitive I feel that you are as
an Aries yes I am very competitive I'm a
Pisces so we're very sensitive crying
and very creative so I I'm just going to
take my waffle batter and divide it up
between six bowls to get some different
colors of the rainbow my Rainbow's done
and when I saw Everly draw the rocks my
first thought was chocolate rocks it
looks like rocks and they are also
colorful like her magical rocks well I
have moved all my batter to bags and
I've got my waffle maker heating up here
so basically I'm just doing Circles of
colors this waffle is a mess right now
we're just gonna see when I open it up
if it's okay we'll see what happens
with the Rocks I'm going to crush up
some cookies to make like dirt so it's
like realistic that looks so real all
right moment of truth oh
that looks so good and I thought it was
going to I'm so relieved
unroll my Swiss roll and then I'm gonna
add some filling it's really good I mean
it's like a little soggy but it's I'm
okay
that tree is not gonna stand okay I am
now moving on to the magical River so
I'm gonna take some yogurt and flavor it
with different like dragon fruit and um
anyway so I'm gonna flavor my yogurt
with different colors and then I'm gonna
put Pop Rocks
kids love Pop Rocks right I do they what
if she's like afraid that's true I do
worry like how mature Everly it's like
taste buds are but if she likes your
sour rainbow she'll probably like some
tart yogurt hopefully I'm making this
River and I'm tasting the yogurt and I
love Greek yogurt but I'm starting to
think like as a kid did I like Greek
yogurt no I think I'm gonna add a little
honey to sweeten this up just a tiny bit
added some like dehydrated strawberries
to get this kind of bread and I'm almost
done I am going to be making shaved ice
over here I will be flavoring it with
different flavors and colors of syrup so
this is vanilla syrup with strawberry
extract
magical and then this is grape syrup oh
this grape serve is kind of dark oh I
love the red now why couldn't the grape
be like that then we have blue raspberry
beautiful River I have to go run and put
this in the freezer and then cut my tree
my magical River components are done and
I think we're getting really close let's
go let's do it this could be a win if I
pull this off but if it just all melts
together
sorry I'm really so all of my components
are here my magical Pond is in the
freezer right now and then I also have
my little dinosaurs who won the audition
it's between these two I think this guy
is going to fit on my plate better
because this is kind of big he's he's a
bigger boy so he's rooting for the
Brontosaurus so yes you won American
Idol American Dino okay I'm sorry this
is kind of the Moment of Truth like if
things are gonna stand are they gonna
fall so what I'm hoping to do is use
some melted chocolate as a glue to help
that tree really stay in place what am I
trying to do here
it's just breaking under the weight of
the expectations that I put up on it
it's not exactly how I pictured it but
you know sometimes you just have to
accept what you have my tree is going to
have a little Bend in it because this is
a round plate we're gonna try to
decorate it now with some frosting some
chocolate frosting and then I'm just
scooping some chocolate rocks and the
dirt I really love the look of my dirt
and my rocks because it looks real what
if she doesn't even want to eat it
because it looks too real you know this
Tree Top just looked better in my head
than on the plate right now I'm trying
to find the perfect placement for this
dinosaur I think that might be it looks
great I'm struggling the way so we're
plating and I'm looking over at Katie
and her tree is just falling apart it's
like it just looks like
[Music]
so I'm going to just lay it flat we're
gonna go 2D I'm pretty sad that the tree
is what it is
thank God I have more tree left it's
actually still very 3D thank you thanks
sweet it's so positive I'm behind at
this point and twice just staring at me
and I'm feeling so much pressure right
now we've got the magical River okay
these are blue Pop Rocks I've got rocks
and we've got the rainbow coming out of
the tree and now for my magical River
oh my God yours looks really good yours
look exactly like the picture so I'm
kind of afraid it's gonna be fun it's
gonna be good
let's go
I really like how my dish turned out so
I think everleigh's Really Gonna like
the tree because she said she loves
chocolate fruit rocks a yogurt River
with pop rocks I really love how the
rainbow waffle turned out though I'm
feeling very confident about that it's
not exactly what I envisioned in my head
but overall I think it came together and
it looks a lot like the photo I'm done
with my dish and by looking at my dish
it has all the components that is in the
drawing a brownie tree some chocolate
covered fruits crumbled up cookies
shaved ice for the magical River and
then DIY fruit straws visually I'm not
that pleased with it I really love my
dinosaur though that guy is cute bring
in my favorite dinosaur food
[Music]
this looks here really yummy that looks
like the tree from a drawing these look
like the Rocks I drew the river looks
very magical I want to try the tree
first fingers crossed
[Music]
this taste is really yummy
great I want to try the rainbow now
yummy it tastes like strawberry she's
only taking like one bite of everything
that she's giving me vague responses
good so I couldn't really read if she
really liked something or if she didn't
I really do you know what your favorite
part is the magical river is my favorite
part
I'm a little worried
looks delish
trees rainbow the river and the rocks
you can see the drawing on my plate my
plate is the drawing this is good
it tasted great
[Music]
I like the Chocolate Tree seems like she
likes it
[Music]
it tasted sour you like sour fruit not
really oh it's sour she doesn't like
sour the river
um it tasted
sour the river is sour I knew it was
gonna be sour I knew it was going to be
tart it is not magical it is sour this
is bad this is very bad fruit
sweet is it good yeah she was saying she
liked the fruit and then she pushed it
off her pork
my favorite part of this dish is the
waffle right now I think it's anyone's
game let's bring in the chefs
did you have fun eating all that food
yeah so which one was your favorite the
first one or the second one
first
yay it was
a surprise thank you so much I'm
definitely going to hang this up in my
new place I'm happy for Troy I'm crying
deep inside for myself first ever win on
I draw you cook so bring on the
competition
thank you